foreign
of Japan Every Spring thousands of
tourists from Japan and overseas descend
upon a shrine in Tokyo's neighboring
prefecture of Kanagawa to celebrate
the penis oh yeah the penis Festival
thingy it's the spring thing don't body
shrimp that's dope the symbol of
fertility is at the center of the
kanamara Matsuri or Festival of the
steel phallus which ranks as one of
Japan's bizarre festivals and the story
behind it is basically this Legend okay
a demon once sought revenge on a woman
who rejected him by taking up residence
inside her vagina and biting down on her
husband's penis so she was unable to
procreate in order to solve the problem
the woman paid a blacksmith to create a
steel phallus to break the Demon's teeth
which he did ultimately restoring her
fertility wow I didn't know that that's
pretty they've been I'm telling you
hentai is a age-old tradition in Japan
it's not a new thing it's a very
convoluted fairy tale it's a good Legend
it should be shared in public school
systems because usually like Western
like it's like night defeats Dragon you
know but then this one it's like the
demon to her [__]
defeat that David have to get a steel
dick and smash it's like I made a story
it's like when YouTube came out and all
these tubers like making stuff and then
everyone's like whoa this is so good hi
I'm here I'm your audience member and
like wow this is so refreshing and
original and different but it's like it
just sucks
but there's nothing else to compare it
to this is not good storytelling yeah
yeah I want to see like the animated
version of this that that's a children's
educational material where it's like you
know what I mean the Demon's sitting
there inside the shadowy vagina that
like you can see through a slit of like
daylight and then when a normal penis
the husband penis comes in and just
bites it and just stops the sperm that's
one thing it's very very very dark and
like aha the Demon's winning then this
giant steel black dick comes in place
it's teeth and it tries to bite and just
shatters it's like an iron dick yeah
dude though America has Iron Man Japan
has iron dick quite a hand tie up and
then the girl meanwhile is like wow this
feels great
thank you for the steel dick in my
vagina so a replica of the phallus and
the spirit of the blacksmith are
preserved at The Shrine called kanayama
here's an image of it this is the
legendary replica of the steel black
smoothie [__] and this this is
celebrated is that like is that like
four NYX is that like
pretty old like centuries old well it's
a replica of it so I mean this is like
just the thing that during the festival
they like bring around it's a it's a
shrine replica oh it's not life-size
because that can't fit into women
yeah yeah yeah we don't like to say that
yeah whoa dude we don't know what tricks
are into however it's like a flagpole
dude there is a penis now that is uh not
as welcome at this Festival so so people
you know like because it's a giant
because of the giant Festival you know
there's things like penis lollipops that
people sell you know they kind of
commercialize a lot of the penis and
phallus stuff uh and more Bachelor
bachelorette party stuff basically but
then Japanese girls have their bachelor
parties there they should maybe there's
one penis that has been created or
erected I should say uh and it's created
so well that it's oftentimes confused
with the legendary symbol so now the
festival and like the officiants are
kind of like hey we need to disassociate
from this other penis that some like fan
of the thing oh because it's too good
yeah so people are like is that the
penis that's not the penis this is the
piano it's a pink one penis yeah so
that's the back side of it though oh
that's like the well this one looks more
like the husband's penis anything but
that's yeah that's exactly yeah it's not
it's not the blacksmith it's a different
name and the legend of the steel penis
is the one that people need to walk away
with In Worship in a sense okay so it's
getting upstaged basically kind of yeah
you can't have like Jesus and then right
next to them you have
right you have like it's like which one
goes no no I know he's more handsome but
we need to do the real Jesus oh yeah
Jesus it's like a Chad Jesus this demon
is a he's quite the incel isn't he he's
he got rejected and then now he's like
well you know what if I can't hear your
[__] nobody can I'll bite all the dicks
that come inside here yeah that's kind
of messed up yeah it's so stupid
swallowing to come so that she can't
procreate by having to go into her room
I know but isn't this deal I'll drink
all the [__] so you can can't get a baby
yeah the Demon's kind of gay yeah and
then the husband's like oh this demon
keeps sucking on my dick and he's all
like oh I'm never gonna [__] [__]
anymore yeah do they have like kids at
these festivals too oh yeah it's a
family I mean they don't censor dicks
right like that like that you know like
but are they ever like eating like are
they ever eating like dick-shaped Foods
probably yeah yeah there's dick [__]
like there's lollipops
on cartoons with kids flashing their
dicks like so it's like mermaids yeah
Little Mermaid Japanese version the
coral bro are there movies or like um
yeah they're movies based on that
storyline but just no it's it's niche
it's like it's like saying like Mardi
Gras or some [__] like it's it's it
exists but like not everyone goes and
knows that's a little weird
see that though come on
or funny what's what's crazy about that
what's crazy about that for you
girl
[Laughter]
yeah like I know that Festival happens
and people go as a guy like it's funny
like it's like a gag right like uh yeah
but then I think
every so like the whole dick and fart
joke thing like I think everyone laughs
at Dicks it's just funny funny it's just
yeah guys girls everybody laughs at
Dicks and then like yeah there's this
cartoon we grew up on where
um I think the US version they edit it
out but like you know how kids always
[__] run around like flash people
yeah yeah and it's a normal like
childhood thing like there's constructed
jokes in there where do he would flash
people and [__] set up punch basically
hey look at me oh one two yeah yeah but
you're like three years old so and you
think it's so funny yeah there's even
like old Stephen child movies where
you'll just have like a kid with his
dick out and he just like has like a
little straw he's like poking the kids
out yeah one of my favorite like uh Hong
Kong films are these two kid monks they
leave the temple one's actually really
good at martial arts and one's more like
for like um comedic relief and he's like
a funny kid likes to eat like a short
fat kid that has to eat everything and
there's one scene where they paint an
elephant on his dick and his dick is the
elephant trunk and for like maybe like
half the movie you see his penis like a
kid's penis and just like a movie that
they played in a theater the movie yeah
bro you ever watched Superman one with
Marlon Brando
dude that movie when they find Clark
Kent he's naked as a [__] days born
and guess what he stands up picking up a
[__] truck yeah and his Dick's out
really it's actually out he's like two
and a half years old and his Dick's out
100 percent
oh I think I remember yeah holy [__] but
it's a Kryptonian dick so you're like
whoa he's kind of hung it's kind of
crazy it's Marlon Brando well Marlon
Brando no is it's a baby it's jorel but
Clark Kent is the councilman is holding
them yeah yeah I can't remember that two
and a half this is another uh this is
another Infamous costume that is being
mistaken for the mascot so another that
guy looks like a crustacean he has a
penis arm
he looks like a Power Rangers villain
gingerbread cookie that guy's like
[__] doing this [__] against the
Power Rangers yeah come on Rangers
[Laughter]
like oh oh it's like dude Sparks go
flying yeah oh so much
they fall on the ground they're crazy
how it goes I think that Festival is
pretty cool we referenced a lot of
different Cinema history that had kids
dicks in them
is there is there thick shame in other
Asian countries because I remember going
to Thailand and I remember like seeing
there was this wood carver and I was
looking at his [__] booth and he had
a whole section of [__] dicks that
were that had a face in it and they were
smiling and happy and then you know like
the Buddha that's like that it was like
that but it was a dick or like and I was
like this is [__] hilarious like they
have a huge that's like in Greece too
they have like those just wooden dicks
and it's just a huge thing to just sell
like the actual penises yeah there's
like a dick flute dick keychain Dick
Tracy I don't know you know
they have it in Bali too oh it's like
big wood carving things yes I honestly I
would just assume that a lot of it is
just Taboo in America maybe it's because
it's like you do something like that
then it's like oh you're gonna get sued
for like 80 billion dollars or some [__]
no I I think America
culture is Puritan so it's like it's
very it's it's like Europe secular now
Puritan but then America is very Puritan
and like just really shuns sex stuff so
Americans like to get mad at stuff too
well that's how they get power trips
like they just like put other things
down it's weird this is not Philippines
loves dicks like you've seen Barrel man
father Karen's [__] about this [__]
have the biggest blackest dildos at home
get the [__] out of here oh probably
they wish they had the steel dick well
because enjoy the demon in her [__]
because that's that's how they see it
they don't they don't see it as like
it's it's bad to do it's bad to admit
you do yes it's it's more about tapping
it in the bedroom yeah it's like that's
for only your husband that's personal
business yeah that's why it's fun
hanging out with Nikki's parents because
they're like like my parents were still
not that way but Nikki's parents are so
open sexually stuff they're like yeah we
[__] and like yeah it's awesome I talk
about pounding their daughter in front
of them and like I've even tried it with
her dad like just trolling them like
hiding height and
oh wow that's awesome are you doing the
stepping on the head thing
the shoes on the background are you
taking your shoes off putting it on your
hands [__] chilling because the
reason why I ask is because I would
totally imagine you do that and it would
still fly
because you're Steve Green I'm gonna try
that this Christmas it's been a newer
bit but I'm gonna see him in next month
and so I'll guess yeah try it out I'll
tell you guys yeah if he knows the
reference you know what kind of porn
he's watching dude honestly you know
what I might actually do
okay I'm gonna get I'm gonna get Nikki
I'm gonna I'm gonna get like um like the
the fake tattoo [__] and have somebody
do a footprint on the back of Nikki's
neck and just like have her walk around
for the weekend and see if her parents
ask about it and I'll be like and then
I'll I'll be like oh [__] sorry that's
from my [__] shoe I don't know like
with a napkin what the like what though
squirm at all when you [__] with her dad
no not at all
this one I [__] with Jill's mom I mean
hey Ma did you hear me in jail last
night she was crazy huh we didn't do
anything we didn't do anything like she
started squirming all over like I don't
know why but I think she has that it's
just kind of awkward between her and my
mom
remember the headboard was [__]
slamming against the wall all night no
Nikki and her dad had an adversarial
relationship when she was growing up and
so now it's like sort of a vuncular like
fun like oh that's cool yeah yeah this
one
foreign